the critics choice is the first time I  came to LA to you know celebrate orphan  black so it got a special place for me  and I and for all of us on the show it's  really cool to be here and apparently  the final season of orphan black will be  really cool too I can see is that the  sisters are very separate at the  beginning of the season and so we see  them in very disparate environment going  through a lot it's a it's a very intense  season I'm halfway through we're  shooting episode 5 as we speak so so I  don't remember anything that's happened  before and I have no idea where we're  going but it's gonna be interested in  the wild ride yes exactly  [Music]  you